um
now that
looks like everyone's ready
i just got back from doing some
reconnaissance you'll want to see this
[Music]
thanks
[Music]
the plan is simple we have two
objectives one
get into our soccer tower and assist v
in accessing mikoshi
and two take advantage of the confusion
to gather as much equipment as we can
prizes like that will see to our cash
flow problem the only way into mikoshi
is to dig through to arasaka towers
underground levels which means we have
to hit the maglev
tunnel construction site and hijack the
nightcorp circ
last but not least intel from our recon
drone
has showed us a couple of weak points
valley leads to the site i doubt they'll
be expecting trouble there
all the same we'll want to move quickly
time is of the essence
we can't allow the guards to call for
backup and if we're too slow
that'll be a job for bob and his jammer
we'll just have to get close to their
comms antenna
and start transmitting let's not kid
ourselves it will install them for long
let's hope it keeps them busy just long
enough
are there drones there early detection
systems anything
it's not fort knox yet nightcorp is
using militech for security so you never
know
i guarantee you the patrolling the area
in any case
our drones will match theirs teddy will
be on the lookout to raise the red flag
construction sites walled in are
panzer's gun big enough for that gate
you bet your ass it is sounds good so
far
what else once you're inside you need to
reach the circ and get it to do your
bidding
enter mitch and carol get that drill up
and running and the road to the sellers
of arasaka tower will be wide open
from there v pan am and i will get to
the laboratory
and find a way into mikoshi and while
we're drilling in
should we expect anyone to crash our
party if everything goes as planned
nobody should know where we are or what
we plan to do
feel free to look around more if you
want you still have some time left
i think i've seen enough
[Music]
well that about does it v you ready
ready as i'll ever be is everyone up to
speed
start your engines folks
[Music]
oh
now that's the site to go
and only this desert expands rivals
those star-studded voids and hangs over
our hands
come take my six
everybody reading loud and clear they've
got us on a group channel
coming to you live from the badlands
this is your home ready
did you fire up that
drone is humming away
you are trespassing on property
protected by militech site secure
turn back now i repeat turn your
vehicles around
this is getting dicey
[Music]
[Music]
is also green we're good to go then let
the fun begin
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
i'll dicado convoy now that's the sights
of the horn
[Music]
and only this desert expanse can rival
them star-studded voids and hangs over
our heads
come take my six
is everybody reading loud and clear i've
got us on a group channel
coming to you live from the badlands
did you fire up that drone the little
bird is humming away
are trespassing on property protected by
militech site secure
turn back now i repeat turn your
vehicles around
this is getting dicey
your turn bobby do you remember the
jammer sure do
we're on it and i've got did you check
if all systems are operational
check it nitro injector clear launcher
is also green
we're good to go then let the fun begin
[ __ ] something's busted all the
circuitry is dead
i'll try to work it out but v you need
to somehow get rid of those drones
on the drones you deal with the panzer
oh no no fire in the cockpit you got
that power surge got it can you put it
out
get the [ __ ] out of god that's a mistake
people where are you
i'm out here by the transmission
a couple of systems will be analogous
jesus christ bobby bobby do you read
we have to go sorry mitch we can't
afford to stop
not now [ __ ] the panzer v it won't hold
up much longer
systems could go down any second i'd do
anything to make it in one piece
anything after that i can improvise
we can do this pan am hang in there
we need to wipe the core folks aside off
the road
you can do this
we're in face she's dying like i said
she would
propulsion weapon systems launchers all
falling like dominoes there anything you
can do about it
i'll try either i do this or this rattle
trap will really be scrap
you get out help our folks we'll provide
cover just hurry all right
so
remember
[Applause]
we have to keep moving we're almost
[Applause]
there
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
huh
uh
[Music]
watch them all right copy that
there's likely a control room upstairs
we can link remotely to the cirque from
there
that's a mistake you'll regret
i got a terminal we're jacking in what
about security protocols
v it's not a space station it's a dumb
big-ass drill
don't worry carol will slice through it
like butter
all right we're firing up the cirque
aiming the boar through to arasaka tower
this will take some time
fee we'll need you to cover us got
company
a lot of it too help us out here
[ __ ] militech is not letting up damn
it's looking like the drill vector's on
auto how can we possibly turn it i'm
gonna sweet talk this [ __ ] into it
mitch kill that autopilot and hit manual
override
got it it's working
[Music]
watch out coming from the right place
[Music]
oh
damn
how much longer 27 percent
i need me an angle
we won't stand a chance without the
panthers
she'll be fine without it
uh
[Music]
[Music]
it's
oh my god what do we do now
what do you think
[ __ ] how much longer up there engaging
almost there nearly at 60 percent
oh
again
i know we'll keep you covered
i can't believe it
[Music]
but i think it worked the love
inside me quick
we're moving on we'll try to buy you as
much time as we can
a bunch of blind let's just watch over
mitch and carol and see to that gate
the millet
[Music]
more company incoming
i might actually pull this off
twiddling going on here we'll buy you as
much time as we can hang in there
oh holy [ __ ] we did it
they're smoldering wrecks we did that
solve mitch head back your way